this is the this is the main issue I
mean part of the reason that you see all
this foolishness on University campuses
too is because people have bought this
idiot meta Marxism which is that the way
to look at every social relationship
that people ever have is through the
lens of power one of the things the
Democrats also have to pay the price for
I would say is their absolute refusal to
draw a line between the moderate
Democrats and the extremists they're
completely incapable of doing that like
I've talked to 40 senators and
congressmen in The Last 5 Years I asked
them all the same same question
including RFK he wouldn't answer either
when does the left go too far well we
certainly bloody well saw it in the last
month didn't we because they got the
oppressor oppressive narrative uh little
mocked up we might say once you decide
these people are the oppressors and
these people people are the oppressed
there is nothing that the oppressed
cannot do to the oppressors